I remember my eyes were like almost
about to cry there is a hint of
embarrassment to be quite honest I
realized that my silence was not
protecting me
it was always a huge concern never tell
anybody anything
my parents always told me never to tell
anybody that I was undocumented so I was
always afraid to to tell anybody up
until that moment the first person I
told that I was undocumented was my high
school vice-principal I told him because
I had just found out that my dad's court
hearing for his residency had been
denied I sort of broke down and I told
him the very first person that I
disclosed my status to was actually a
high school friend high school was a big
challenge for me because while everybody
was getting their drivers license or
getting jobs I was like oh I can't get
that I wondered if this was going to
question our friendship actually the
first person that I taught was my ninth
grade computer ed teacher miss Mitchell
she offered me a summer job and the
first thing that she asked me was for my
parents permission and a social security
number which I didn't have
she looked mad and I was like the first
time across my mind was like oh my god
she's totally gonna tell of me but she
was like I can't believe that you know
somebody who has so much potential you
know is it's being doesn't it's not a
given an opportunity to get papers I
began a question like what am i doing in
high school you know should I even
continue high school should I graduate I
should just drop out you know what's the
point I was really afraid
uh-huh just because I'm afraid of being
judged mainly and I knew about secrets
because aside from being undocumented
I'm also queer I just needed somebody to
know I needed somebody even if that
person couldn't help me I just needed
somebody else to know who I really was
and the identity that I was carrying
with me
I don't ever remember feeling ashamed
about being undocumented my father was
deported when I was in 10th grade and
that's when I came came to understand
what it meant to be undocumented it was
always something that was that was on my
mind it was always on my on my horizon
and just rapping about it making jokes
about it made it all the more bearable
coming out as undocumented and queer
means owning your narrative that I exist
that I'm a person that I'm here that my
existence is more than a nine digit
number sticking it to the man loving
yourself being tired of seeing the
injustice that goes on in our community
being unafraid it's like the boogeyman
that's gonna get you you you come face
to face of it and it's gone it means
love for myself for my identity for my
community when you are in the shadows or
in the closet you're you're alone but
once you express yourself and you become
active in the community there's this
liberation and empowerment coming out as
undocumented is really liberating you
never know who will be your biggest
supporter and also it forces people to
see us and to recognize that we're here
you